oui bravo j'aime bien c'est là que je te
reconnais es j'aime bien Jacques je te
jure bravo marginal bravo c'est un
marginal les Chéries dans un instant une
femme de 24 de 84 ans entre la vie et la
mort après avoir été violemment agressée
en promenant son chien le cri du cœur de
Sandra la fille de la victime dans T P
vous avez tous vu cette image c'est
incroyable et apparemment l'agresseuse
et dehors
est dehors actuellement on va vous
raconter cette histoire qui est
complètement folle et ce témoignage pour
le moment on va donc parler de
l'émission de Jacques cardose en quête
complémentaire une émission qui semble
faire peur à certains et le Parisien a
publié un article hier disant que
l'enquête faisait peur au groupe Canal
Plus groupe dont nous faisons partie et
que l'enquête ne serait pas diffusée et
forcément ça a eu le don de m'énerver
parce que je suis producteur et donc je
me suis dit pour prouver qu'elle va être
diffusée on va commencer à la diffuser
dès ce
soir en balançant trois extraits puisque
l'enquête est terminée ou encore
peut-être rajouter des petites choses
qui vont tomber enc ça tombe toujours
mais l'enquête en tout cas pratiquement
finie et on va le
diffuser dès que on le sentira et dès
qu'on sentira que le Parisien et France
Télévision nous auront fait cette
bot pour l'instant vra on attend je
vrais les remercier car ils nous ont
fait un tel buz que tout le monde va
attendre l'enquête et donc aujourd'hui
tout le monde attend les extraits donc
merci aux Parisiens merci [__] pour nous
mettre un petit coup de pression merci à
eux voilà donc je les embrasse fort et
continuer dans ce sens ça ne fait que
faire monter le nombre de
téléspectateurs merci à eux Jacques
cardose on va mettre trois extraits dans
votre enquête vous avez mis en lumière
la diffusion de fake news au sein des
évision émissions d'Élise Lucé et de
Tristan baldex oui il s'agit le premier
chapitre d'une fake news qui est passé
presque inaperçu ce qui est marrant
c'est que c'est la première fois et la
seule fois presque que Tristan ou Alex
et éise Luc ét aux commande d'une même
émission c'était ils avaient appelé ça
une spéciale d'envoyer consacré au
glyphosate et ils avaient eu l'idée de
faire des glyphotests et le problème
c'est que ces glyphotest étaient
totalement bidon ça avait fait un
scandale en interne c'est passé presque
inaperçu on regarde le prier extrait
lancement ils sont hyper longs non VO
vous êtes journaliste moi j'aurais lancé
ça voilà bon alors dans son enquête il
dit voilà les fake new
regardez au premier rang de ces erreurs
le glyphotest que la journaliste a fait
passer panel de Français dont les
résultats ont de quoi surprendre
effectivement ils ont voulu dans cette
émission montrer aux gens montrer aux
public que tout le monde a du glyphosate
dans ses urines et pour ça ils ont monté
ce glyphotest et malheureusement ils s
sont mal pris parce que ils ont décidé
d'envoyer les prélèvements d'urine dans
un laboratoire allemand qui s'appelle
biochck créé par une dame qui s'appelle
Monica Krueger militante antiglyphosate
et il se trouve que on a su de manière
certaine que les analyses faites par le
laboratoire biotck sont fausses sont pas
fouté alors ce qui est encore plus grave
c'est qu'à la suite de cette émission
Cyril plusieurs journalistes et ses
experts scientifiques ont été menacés
enfin l'une d'elles a été menacée jusque
dans sa vie privée parce que précisément
ils avaient révélé que les glyphotest
était bidon on écoute le deuxème
témoignage ah tu fais ta vie toi ça a
été terrible parce que moi j'ai été
attaqué ma vie privée ils ont ils ont
essayé de joindre mes proches ma porte a
été forcée deux fois ils ont essayé de
me faire virer ils ont appelé mon patron
en disant que je faisais des trucs dans
son dos ce qui était pas vrai
heureusement que j'ava eu un patron
solide qui savait que c'était faux parce
que sinon j'aurais été diré quoi ça a
été terrible terrible
terrible selon cette journaliste c'est
le cahier des charges des émissions
d'investigation de france télé qui est à
remettre en cause cette quête
perpétuelle du scandale aboutit à des
enquêtes baclées voir tr ok vous êtes
journaliste vous savez comme moi qu'on
peut pas déterer un scandale par semaine
c'est pas possible et quand votre cahier
décharge c'est de dénoncer du scandale
du scandale du scandale ben forcément
vous montez en épingle des scandales qui
n'en sont pas pour moi c'est du
journalisme d'insinuation i spécial je
pense qu'elle a des compes personnels à
régler avec le monde entier ça coûte une
fortune à faire cette émission je sais
pas comment ils ont réussi à sauver ce
truc là et je pense qu'elle a des
dossier sur tout le monde et qu'elle est
indéboulonable vous vous allez lancer un
trè extrait mais je vais lancer moi
après il est très fort alors allez-y dé
lancer votre non je précise juste que
les menaces dont elle dit avoir été
victime on on a jamais su si euh elle
provenait de journalistes par que je
n'ose évidemment pas imaginer ou de gens
qui avaient intérêt à ce qu'on ne
remette pas en cause ce discours qui
consistait à défoncer quoi qu'il arrive
le le le glyphosate parce qu'il y a des
intérêts financiers on l'explique dedans
il y a des intérêts financiers via le
bio voilà alors il s'agit pas de dire
dans le sujet d'ailleurs que c'est bien
ou pas bien
c'est pas du tout ça il s'agit juste
dire que il y a des éléments fake news
qui ont été utilisés vous êtes intéressé
au processus de nomination de la
présidente de France Télévision
également et là ça pour moi c'est
l'extrait le plus problématique de de ce
soir alors là là il y a plusieurs
révélations plusieurs révélations sur ce
processus de domination nomination oui
dont François Hollande avait dit qu'il
serait très transparent on se souvient
de sa fameuse phrase moi Président je ne
nommerai pas le président de France Télé
et ce
écoutez c'est parlant vous allez
voir dans cette affaire nous irons de
surprise en surprise en coulisse le CSA
annonce que les noms des candidats
resteront
secrets voici le procès verbal de
l'audition du président du CSA avez-vous
jamais reçu des conseils de la part du
président de la République j'ai reçu un
coup de téléphone de François Holland
qui m'a demandé d'éviter de nommer
mariechistine saragos et Emmanuel HOG
oui oui président de la République
François Hollande m'a passé un coup de
fil pour vous dire quoi bah que il
fallait pas mettre en place des PDG qui
étaient déjà en
exercice mais de quel droit n'était-ce
pas allé à l'encontre de vos propres
engagements non j'exprimais une position
celle de l'État le CSA était totalement
libre d'en tenir compte ou pas moi
président de la République je n'aurais
pas la prétention de nommer les
directeurs des chaînes de télévision
publique je laisserai ça à des instances
indépendantes c'est énorme
parce que en fait françoisand il nomme
pas mais il dit ceux qu'il faut pas
nommer comme il y a trois candidats bon
tu dois pas nommer lui et lui bah
forcément c'est comme dans le jeu de
Jean-Luc rechman lui lui ou l'autre bah
c'est non mais c'est vrai non mais
franchement là c'est la partie la plus
la plus enquêtée j'ai envie de dire la
plus investigation où il y a beaucoup de
révélations sur tout ce processus qui
est très opaque on nous avait promis une
grande transparence il y a plusieurs
épisodes je vais pas tous les raconter
mais il y a des dossiers qui ont disparu
on prétend que les certaines auditions
n'ont jamais existé il y a des membres
du CSA qui n'ont jamais été reçus et
tout est dans le l'enquête
complémentaire c'est alors euh on a un
autre extrait si vous voulez est-ce que
vous en voulez un autre ou for vre
enquête pouveit également alors là là on
vous a pas mis les extraits les plus
forts sur le parce que voilà mais on va
vous mettre d'autres votre extrait
prouve également que france télé ne
respecte pas son devoir de neutralité
oui à travers la la plateforme slash ah
oui ça c'est fou ils n'ont pas hésité à
lancer des appels au don pour le comité
Adamas Traoré il faut savoir il faut que
tout le monde le sache que lorsqu'on est
une télévision publique on a des
obligations de neutralité on n pas à
prendre parti pour un comité ou un autre
il s'agit pas de se prononcer sur le
fait que c'était bien ou pas bien c'est
pas le sujet le sujet c'est que c'est
une position politique ils n'ont pas
hésité à la voir et on va le voir dans
l'extcroyable ça sur slash il y a des
scandales manifestes souscouvert de
diversité qui a eu des pétitions pour le
comité Adama Traoré la famille Traoré
c'est une famille qui défie l'État c'est
une honte pour notre pays c'est une
honte pour la justice
française France Télévision a une
obligation de neutralité et puis surtout
d'apporter une pluralité d'opinion on
devrait avoir toutes les opinions
représentant tous les Français autour de
la table lorsque sont diffuser ses
contenus la justice ne s'est encore pas
prononcé sur la mort tragique d'Adama
Traoré mais la télévision publ elle
choisit son camp et se fait l'écho du
combat de la sœur contre les violences
policières France tv/ appelle à faire
des dons à des associations politique
par exemple on vous incite à faire des
dons l'association comité pour Adama de
Assad Traoré ces dons en fait permettent
de payer les frais de justice de la
famille Traoré et de faire face selon
les mots d'ASS Traoré à cette machine de
guerre qui est l'état français je suis
pas en train de vous dire que c'est bien
que c'est pas bien c'est pas l'endroit
pour le faire sur le service public en
tout cas c'est illégal en tout cas moi
ce que j'aime c'est qu'on voit des gens
à visage ouaiscouvertcouvert et qu'on
voit des mecs qui viennent vraiment
témoigner pas avec des voix et des
silhouettes ça c'est très fortors j'en
parle pas mais je le Tise il y a une
réaction d'un hautdigeant de France
Télévision qui m'appelle au lendemain de
la diffusion du complément d'enquête sur
toi ah oui donc j'en dis pas plus non
mais dis-nous non j'en dis pas plus non
mais qu'est-ce qu'il dit en bah elle
prend ta défense ah oui une une antienne
une responsable de France Télévision qui
prend ta défense qui est actuellement
là-bas h ah oui h ah bien sûr ouis j'ai
encore des amis là-bas tu sais
c'est vrai encore des amis là-bas bah
merci en tout cas c'est fort tu le mets
dans le dans le doc ça ah bah oui bien
sûrah ou donc c'est pour ça regardz alle